j'ai tendance à me dire que ce qui est
le plus important d'abord d'abord c'est
de voir des films
évidemment c'est toujours mieux quand on
les voit en salles de cinéma mais quand
on habite à paris à lyon ou à marseille
ou à new york ou à rome c'est assez
facile de dire ça il ya beaucoup
d'endroits où beaucoup de terrains ou
territoire dans lequel les salles de
cinéma sont pas si accessible que ça aux
états unis vous sortez des grandes
villes il ya quasiment plus de salles
art et essai par exemple donc moi
j'aurais tendance à dire oui
effectivement c'est très important de
voir les films en salle mais ce n'est
pas exclusif le plus important me
semble-t-il c'est de ces deux c'est de
voir des films
donc je pense que la salle de cinéma un
avenir le vrai problème en france c'est
qu'on a cinq 5 ou 6000 écran qu'on a
3000 salles de cinéma est ce que par
rapport à la à l'évolution des
spectateurs aujourd'hui par rapport à la
jeune génération moi qui m'obsède un peu
parce que les crânes gris et les shows
dans les salles art et essai je me dis
que dans dix ans ils sont plus là donc
faut s'intéresser à la génération qui
vient
et cette génération qui vient est ce que
le parc de cinéma n'est pas un peu me
semble-t-il surdimensionné par rapport
par rapport à l autrement dit est-ce que
le modèle d'exploitation et de
distribution qui a fait des grands jours
du cinéma en france dans les années
60-70 c'est même encore un peu 80's
qu'il est encore à la taille bon voilà
mesure de nous prédire de l'appétit à
déterminer d'ailleurs de pour la jeune
génération pour le cinéma est ce que la
jeune génération a autant un désir de
cinéma que la mienne par exemple ou que
la nôtre ça c'est à mon avis une vraie
question est qui va produire sans doute
des bouleversements un peu tectoniques
presque indépendant de la question de la
plateforme la plateforme neiges
elle s'inscrit dans lé dans les failles
ldlc com la nature elle a horreur du
vide et qu'elle voit qu'il ya un truc à
faire elle y va donc elle profite à la
fois elle a sa vie propre mais elle
profite aussi des faiblesses on pourra
dire vous d'un métamorphose du cinéma en
gros la question moi que je me pose
c'est est ce que le cinéma est encore ou
pas un art populaire
c'est ça la vraie question
[Musique]